is uh what exactly should be given by
way of Zak and as a second part of the
question is money allowed to be given as
far as giving of Zak is concerned it
should be given in the form of food it
can be dates can be barley can be wheat
can be rice it can be raisin it can be
oats it can be any staple food whatever
the staple food of that country of that
City if it's wheat give wheat if it's
rice give rice if it date give date and
it is unanimously agreed that it should
be in the form of food and it can be
preferable in the form of any grain like
wheat rice Etc and I beloved Prophet M
wasallam said it's mentioned
inkari number two in the book of zakat
Hadith number
153 narrated
Omar with him he said that Allah's
messenger has enjoined to give One S of
dates or One S of bar
as for every Muslim slave or free male
or female young or
old and it should be given before the
Salah there's another Hadith mentioned
Inari number two in the book of Z Hadith
number 151 Z narrated Abu Al that at the
time of Mami wasallam we used to give
One S of food as Zak and our food used
to be barley it used to be raisins
pottage cheese and dates so all these
things are mentioned in the Hadith it's
mentioned in a
of Hadith number 2417 Abbas pleas with
him he said the S of Ramadan that is
is Van if someone gives vat then it
should be accepted if someone gives date
it should be accepted if someone gives
reason it should be accepted so these
are the various types mentioned in the
Hadith but in short it's understood that
it should be food preferbly in the form
of
grain and as far as the question is
concerned that can we give something
else like money Etc it's unanimous
agreement that it should be food you
can't give anything else you can't give
money you cannot give any clothes to the
po man or some furniture if you want to
give it as normal charity you can't give
anything but as far as Zak is concerned
it should be given in the form of food
and it's clearly mentioned in the Hadith
in the Hadith I quoted that it should be
given before the eat prayer the reason
is that the poor man at least has
something to eat on that day if you give
him money he may keep for some other
time Etc so it should be in the form of
food so at least his stomach is full and
he doesn't have to bother about eating
for that day of Festival so it's
agreement that it should be given in the
form of food you can
give the equivalent amount of money to a
responsible person or any charitable
organization who says that okay with
this money we'll buy the amount of food
and give it to the very poor man or the
need man but finally when it reaches the
recipient it should be in the form of
food I know that there are some people
who say that you can give in the form of
money to the poor man but there's no
Hadith at all whatsoever so giving your
own opinion based on no Hadith and no
backing Quran Sunnah it's not allowed
and as it's mentioned in s bukari volume
number three Hadith number
2697 a be pleased with her she said that
anyone who innovates something in the
dean in the religion it has to be
rejected and it's mentioned in say
Muslim volume number three Hadith number
4267 that the Beloved Prophet wasallam
said that anyone who brings something
new in the of Islam it has to be
rejected so getting anything new
innovation is not allowed at all Zak
should be given in the form of food as
mentioned in the Hadith it cannot be
given in the form of money or anything
else as normal charity it can be given
but zakat should be in the form of food
some people argue saying that at the
time of the Prophet there was no
currency there was no paper money you
know that's why zakat wasn't given in
the form of money but today we can give
the fail to realize that at the time of
the prophet and at the time of sahabas
there were dams there were dinar there
were it was not in the form of paper
currency but there was money where
people used to use in the form of dam
and dinar so to use this argument is
totally wrong so the right thing is that
it should only be given in the form of
food and nothing else